THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANKLE.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THE RUSSIANS
LIKE THE CHINESE, THEY ARE
MASTERS OF PROPAGANDA.
THEY USE IT TO CONTROL THEIR
PEOPLE BY CONTROLLING THE
INFORMATION FLOW.
SADLY, IN THE UNITED STATES, OU
CURRENT LEADERSHIP RELEASES ITS
OWN SHARE OF PROPAGANDA ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
CONSIDER THEIR FRAMING OF THE
MUCH ANTICIPATED TALKS BETWEEN
CHINESE AND U.S. OFFICIALS IN
ROME THAT JUST WRAPPED.
THE FOCUS WAS CHINA'S ROLE IN
BACKSTOPPING RUSSIA AND UKRAINE
WHAT COULD BE DONE NEXT FRIDGES
SO WHERE THE BIDEN TEAM WANT YO
TO REMEMBER IS INTENSE, AS IN
THE NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
HAD AN INTENSE MEETING WITH THE
TOP CHINESE DIPLOMAT.
IT WAS AN INTENSE SEVEN HOUR
SESSION REFLECTING THE GRAVITY
OF THE MOMENT AND IT WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT YOU'VE HEARD OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR RELAY
PUBLICLY ABOUT WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES WOULD BE.
>> AS SENIOR OFFICIALS SAID CNB
THAT THEY THAT THE U.S. IS
CONCERNED THAT BEIJING MAY
ATTEMPT TO HELP RUSSIA LOCKS UP
LOCAL SANCTIONS HE WAS DIRECT
ABOUT THOSE CONCERNS AND THE
POTENTIAL IMPLICATIONS AND
CONSEQUENCES OF CERTAIN ACTIONS
TRANSLATION, SULLIVAN GOT
NOTHING.
AND TRY NOT YONDER.
HERE IS HOW CHINA SAW THAT
MEETING.
HE HAS PROPOSED MUTUAL RESPECT,
AND WIN-WIN COOPERATION AS THE
THREE PRINCIPLES OF DEVELOPING
CHINA AND U.S. RELATIONS IN THE
NEW ERA.
U.S. PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
RESPONDED POSITIVELY WITH SUCH
IMPORTANT COMMITMENTS IS THAT
THE U.S. DOES NOT SEEK A NEW
COLD WORK OR TO CHANGE CHINA
SYSTEM NOR WILL IT OPPOSE CHINA
THROUGH STRENGTHENING ALLIANCE,
SUPPORT TAIWAN INDEPENDENCE, OR
SEEK CONFRONTATION WITH CHINA.
CHINA THAN REFERENCED UKRAINE A
THE END AS AN AFTERTHOUGHT.
IN WASHINGTON, WHEN A HIGH LEVE
MEETING FIZZLES, AND YIELDS NO
DELIVERABLES AS THEY CALL THEM,
YOU SEND A SPOKESMAN OUT TO SPI
THE ATMOSPHERE.
AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT, IT WAS
NO WORD SIGNIFYING NOTHING.
LISTEN TO THE PASSIVE VERBS
CONNOTING AMERICA AS AN OBSERVER
.
>> WE ARE WATCHING VERY CLOSELY
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE POC OR
ANY OTHER COUNTRY FOR THAT
MATTER PROVIDES ANY FORM OF
SUPPORT ANY SUCH SUPPORT FROM
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD WOULD BE
OF GREAT CONCERN TO US.
THIS IS NAKED AGGRESSION.
THIS IS A WAR OF CHOICE, THIS I
A COUNTRY, ONE INDIVIDUAL AT TH
TOP OF THAT COUNTRY, VIOLATING
IN A BRAZEN MANNER WHAT HAD BEE
THE CARDINAL RULES OF THE
INTERNATIONAL ORDER FOR THE PAS
SEVEN YEARS.
>> FIRST, RUSSIA DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT OUR WATCHING WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
THEY CARE ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING
.
RIGHT NOW WERE DOING NOTHING,
BUT MAKING CHINA RICHER BY THE
DAY.
NEARLY $50 BILLION WORTH OF
GOODS WE BUY FROM THEM EACH
MONTH.
RUSSIA IS WATCHING THAT TOO.
SECOND, WHY ARE WE ACTING AS IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER CHINA IS EVEN HELPING
RUSSIA?
EVEN IF THEY'RE NOT SELLING
WEAPONS DIRECTLY TO CHINA, CHIN
IS GIVING THEM HOPE BY BUYING
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS IN THEIR
OIL.
SO THIS IS A TOTAL END RUN
AROUND WESTERN SANCTIONS, WE'VE
BEEN SAYING THAT FOR TWO PLUS
WEEKS.
THERE IT, AS I'VE SAID FOR YEARS
, CHINA DOES NOT CARE ABOUT
THE RULES OF THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY.
NEITHER DOES RUSSIA.
SO INVOKING THEM PIOUSLY DOESN'
GET YOU ANYWHERE, IT DOESN'T GE
YOU ANY RESPECT.
THIS WAS AS FAR AS THE STATE
DEPARTMENT GOT WHEN I CAME TO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR PRUDENT
BANKERS IN BEIJING.
>> WE HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR BOTH
PRIVATELY COME UP WITH BEIJING,
PUBLICLY WITH BEIJING, THAT
THERE WOULD BE CONSEQUENCES.
WE WILL NOT ALLOW ANY COUNTRY T
COMPENSATE RUSSIA.
THERE IS A LOT FOR THEM TO
EXPLAIN.
>> NICE TRY, BUT NONE OF THESE
THREATS AT UP TO ANYTHING OTHER
THAN A HUGE FLUFF.
THE REAL POWER BROKERS AND THE
MINISTRATION AREN'T ONBOARD WIT
THIS.
CHINA HAS THE HIGHEST PAID
LOBBYIST INSIDE THE BELTWAY AND
THEY KNOW THAT JOHN KERRY HE IS
THE GUY WHO REALLY COUNTS HERE,
HE PUTS CLIMATE CHANGE AHEAD OF
EVERY OTHER ISSUE FACING AMERICA
.
AND THEY KNOW THAT HE IS
DESPERATE FOR TIGHTNESS HELP ON
THE ISSUE IS STUPID IS THAT IS.
THEY ALSO KNOW THAT THEY HAVE A
FRIEND IN BIDEN TREASURY
SECRETARY JANET YELLEN WHO HAS
SAID THAT TRUMPS OLD TIME THAT
TARIFFS OUR TO INFLATION NOW.
THIS IS GREAT NEWS FOR CHINA
WHICH OF COURSE WANTS TO DROP
THE TARIFF.
AND OF COURSE CHINA ALSO KNOWS
THAT JOE BIDEN HIMSELF, WHO SON
GOT WEALTHY FOR DUBIOUS WORK IN
CHINA HAD SAID THAT CHINA'S
GROWTH IS NOT A THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES.
>> CHINA IS GOING TO THEIR NOT
BAD FOLKS, FOLKS.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
THEY'RE NOT COMPETITION FOR US.
>> WHAT ARE THE ACTUAL CHANCES
THAT THE FEEBLEMINDED AYDIN IS
GOING TO STAND UP TO JOHN KERRY
JENNY THE MYRIAD OF BUSINESS AN
FINANCIAL INTEREST DURING
CHINA'S BIDDING?
WHAT ABOUT THE ODDS HE'LL TAKE
ON THE MEDIA ESTABLISHMENT THAT
LOVES AND PROTECTS CHINA 24/7?
THE ANSWER, ZERO.
NO CHANCE.
AND UNDERSTANDING HE HOW XI SEE
THAT IS CRITICAL TO ANY ACTION.
RIGHT NOW HE SEES AS IS A POWER
INTO IN DECLINE HE SEES IS AS
WEAK IN SELF LOATHING.
A COUNTRY CULTURALLY DEPLOYED
AND DIVIDED.
FIGHT HE SEES HIS COMMUNIST
SYSTEM AS SUPERIOR IN EVERY WAY.
HE'S A NATIONALIST, AND HE'S
AIMING FOR NOTHING SHORT OF
GLOBAL DOMINATION.
TO GET THERE, HIS PRIORITIES
RANGE FROM THE SUBSTANTIVE, THE
BELT ROAD INITIATIVE TYPE STUFF
COMMITTED THEIR FRIVOLOUS LIKE
HIS BANDING EFFEMINATE MALE
CHARACTERS ON TV.
REMEMBER THAT?
BY THE WAY, WHEN HE DID THAT
THING WITH THE EFFEMINATE MALE
CHARACTERS, HE KNEW THE AMERICA
FILM INDUSTRY WOULD NEVER
PROTESTER COMPLAINED THAT THAT
WAS DISCRIMINATORY OR ANTI-
LGBTQ.
THEY WOULDN'T COMPLAIN ONE BIT.
ONE AS LAST TIME YOU SAW A
CHINESE VILLAIN ON THE BIG
SCREEN?
AND XI NOTICED KEY GOP
ESTABLISHMENT FIGURES THEY WON'
LOSE SLEEP ABOUT CHINA'S
MONOPOLIZATION OF KEY INDUSTRIES
.
THE ONLY THING THAT MOTIVATES
THEM IS MONEY.
AND A LOT OF MONEY FIGHTS CHINA
A LOT OF POLITICAL COVER IN
CONGRESS.
XI KNOWS ALL OF THIS BECAUSE HE
HAS WATCHED IT UNFOLD OVER THE
PAST 25 YEARS.
WHICH BRINGS US BACK TO THE
CURRENT NIGHTMARE IN UKRAINE.
BIDEN COULD DEMAND THAT JOHN
KERRY GO OUT AND SAY THE
MINISTRATION IS PUTTING CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS ON HOLD AT LEAST A
CHINA REMAINS IN DESTABILIZING
FORCE ON THE WORLD, HE COULD
ALSO SAY THAT AS LONG AS THEY
CCV IS TRYING TO BUY PROXY
OVERTHROW THAT ZELENSKYY IN
UKRAINE WERE NOT GOING TO
ABANDON OUR OIL INDUSTRY, BUT O
COURSE THE BIDEN PEOPLE WOULD
NOT DO SOMETHING SENSIBLE.
AS A RESULT, WE MIGHT AS WELL
JUST HAVE AN ADULT BEVERAGE
BECAUSE WE HAVE ZERO LEVERAGE.
COUNTRIES FORMALLY HELPFUL FOR
THE U.S. ARE LOOKING EASTWARD.
THINK ABOUT SAUDI ARABIA, WHICH
JUST INVITED XI FOR A VISIT
AMIDST ANOTHER BLUNDER BY THE
UNITED STATES.
THE U.S. IS EITHER AT THIS POINT
, LOOKING AT OTHER THINGS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED, THEY'RE
EITHER GOING TO GET STRONGER BY
GETTING ITS OWN ECONOMIC HOUSE
IN ORDER AND BEGIN DECOUPLING
FROM THE REGIMES LIKE CHINA, OR
THE WORLD IS GOING TO GET MORE
DANGEROUS AND MORE CHAOTIC.
IN THE MEANTIME, THE ONLY
UKRAINE NEGOTIATIONS THAT ARE
GOING TO HAPPEN IN THIS SCENARI
ARE THE TYPES OF NEGOTIATIONS
THAT LET SAY GO ON BETWEEN A CA
AND MOUSE.
THE CAT IS GOING TO TOY AROUND
WITH THE MOUSE, THAN POUNCE WHE
THE TIME IS RIGHT